hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast disparities in colorectal
cancer presented by dr. John Carruthers
who is a John G Searle professor of
internal medicine and professor and
chair in the department of internal
medicine professor of human genetics at
UM HS internal medicine in the
university of michigan i'm susie valdez
of lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of our
presentation also please notice that you
are viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon located at the lower
left if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing educational
credits please click on the button at
the bottom left hand corner and follow
the process for obtaining your credits
without further ado please welcome dr.
John Carruthers I will now turn the
presentation over him welcome sir and so
as with most cancers
developed in a genetically susceptible
individual meaning you had the genetic
makeup that could possibly develop
cancer however typically unless it's a
classic germline mutation in which puts
you at extremely high risk
most of these but you have a low risk
however if you have the right exposure
that interacts with that genetically
susceptible individual you can develop a
cancer and that's what I will called the
amine environmental interaction and
here's some examples on this slide you
could take a genetically susceptible
individual exposing to human papilloma
virus and you could develop a server
core a nor head neck cancer likewise and
not going through every example you
could have someone who is developing
planetary bodies information and
ultimately develop colon cancer not
everyone who is genetically susceptible
develops a cancer but the right
interaction can make that interplay and
then allow that cancer to develop even
everyone who smokes doesn't get a lung
cancer although that's the leading cause
of lung cancer but not everyone who
smokes gets a lung cancer they may have
other lung diseases but certainly in the
genetics is a well individual your
chance of getting lung cancer are vastly
higher than someone who doesn't smoke in
the colon the process of developing a
cancer usually starts and on the top of
this slide you can see that there is a
depiction of progression from a
hyperbola first eight where you get a
small bump on the inner line in a colon
and that could grow due to uncontrolled
proliferation in a benign state and to
get just as of a larger pot that you
could see
in six examples here at colonoscopy if
that Paul continues to grow and
proliferate they can acquire other
mutations within the cells of that polyp
that can turn into more of a malignant
state or what we call cancer and then
that cancer can invade and spread in a
bomb aside our six just endoscopic
examples these are pictures taken at the
time of colonoscopy examples of what we
see for instance in the upper left here
this is a typical exa Finnick adenoma
there in the middle panel here this is a
little more complex it's oblong but this
is still a benign lesion and then on the
upper right here you'll see a very large
adenoma with a very fat
EXO Finnick base and this is still a
benign in the bottom left is another
example with a long stalk with the
adenoma at the very tip there now in
this bottom middle panel this is much
more of a lesion and this was boxy to
show that and had cancer so this started
as a pop that might have been flat but
then turn into cancer and then on the
bottom right here is another example of
a very very flat very gated widespread
lesion that turns out as a cancer on the
next slide are a few more examples of
this even in hot with high-resolution
colonoscopy in the upper left a typical
small polyp this is probably the most
common thing we see when we do
colonoscopy and those appropriate for
colonoscopy in the middle panel another
little more complex and Noma and then on
the upper right here is a large example
of a polyp an animal - polyp that has an
ulcer in the middle of it there that
turns out that was where the cancer
started in the bottom left are a
specific type of animals because how
serrated polyps they tend to be on
right side of the colon and with high
resolution colonoscopy you can see the
pitting patterns on the surface of this
serrated polyp in the bottom middle
another example with under narrowband
imaging this is a special technique
where you have only certain light shown
and you can see the vascular pattern of
the polyp and in the bottom right here's
one with a sessile traited palate of
which the yellow arrows show an area
than the basic hands sometimes these can
be very subtle but the suffice it to say
that most colon cancers develop from the
polyps and the type of pops that
progress to cancer typically adenoma
source uh Sarita adenoma and these are
defined as these EXO Finnick lesions
that are already dysplastic under the
microscope apologist and it's thought to
progress from the normal to this pop
stage to a cancer stage over decades for
most people now on this next slide as an
example of cancers so I showed you as
some cancers in a pop but the two exams
at the top of this slide are very large
lesions that even partially obstruct the
partially or fully obstruct the entire
movement of the large intestine or core
in the upper right this covered 50% of
the lumen a very large cancer and on the
upper right one that what we will call
an annular lesion that's that's growing
across the entire circumference of the
colon
on the bottom right depicts this in a
more graphic sense and this is taken
from the National Cancer Institute
website that shows early stage where the
lesion is on the inside of the bow and
if plucked off is gone but you get to
stage 2 where there's invasion of the
cancer invades the muscle layer
that may require surgery to remove and
you get to stage
sorry that was stage one stage two which
in which it's gone through the muscle
layer and stage to me has spread to some
of the lymph nodes in stage four means
there's general metastasis that have
spread beyond this organ and so that's
what we call staging and that could
determine your survival the more
advanced stage the less likely your
survive long term now how common is
colon cancer in the United States it's
estimated that there will be over
135,000 people who develop colon cancer
in 2017 and fifty will die from cancer
now I have to be at the University of
Michigan let me at the largest stadium
in North America and that's Michigan
Stadium and that capacity' stadium is
over a hundred seven thousand now if I
told you that everyone that stadium
would die this year and then another
third of the stadium you probably be
greatly apart but that's the how many
people die of Chloe but cancer it's a
stadium as a one point three of these
stadiums and if I told you half that
will get colon cancer I'm sorry but half
the stadium will die that you can get a
sense on how many people that is when
you put it in that context now the best
way to take care cancers not to get it
at all and for colorectal cancer that is
generally done by screen now what is
Street screening is a way to try to find
the precursor to cancers and prevent the
cancer from forming and but it must meet
some general guidelines that is whatever
tests that you use for screening should
be sensitive and be able to detect what
you are testing so in other words you
are able to find it
if the test is the test for that it
should be specific in other words does
not detect the cancer when negative and
it should be a condition that's broad
enough common enough and represented in
population if you're the rare bird that
it's one in two million persons no one's
going to screen 200 million people the
screen to find that one person but if in
colon cancer the numbers are large
screening can prevent that it should be
cost effective if you spend ten million
dollars per person to do screening
that's not going to cost effective for
society also the test should do little
or no harm in other words whatever tests
you you pick for screening should cause
more morbidity than the thing you're
trying to prevent and it should reduce
mortality in other words the test should
prevent you from developing the cancer
and thus you would have and so this is
absolutely true for many types of
screening cool enhancing it so the
colorectal cancer here is a slide that
just shows four common cancers that we
screen for breast in women cervical
cancer in women prostate cancer and
colorectal cancer now if you look at the
numbers for the instance in the United
States and 2017 you see that colorectal
cancers not be most common cancer it's
actually behind actually hmong which is
not on this slide but the gender
gender-based cancers breast and prostate
are more common but if you look at the
deaths of these commonly screen four
cancers it is the most common cause of
death more so than breast and prostate
and if you look at the types of
screening the types of methods to screen
freeze cancers breast cancers lodging
mammography and in the literature and
him in the media recently there's been
some controversy on the age of screening
because of the ability for this
specificity but it's still a decent
screening method when used appropriately
sir milk answers jelly screen by pap
smears so there's one test for both of
these classics cancer screening has
happened PSAs but that's entered
controversy and it's sensitivity
specificity is questioned and so there
are other methods being detected first
screening that in combination of a
rectal exam is Joey what it's been used
in the past but look at colorectal
cancer so much common a common cause of
death and we've invented seven or eight
tests for that
each with its different system
specificity and more recently based on
July 2017 guidelines published in
gastroenterology they have broken down
the types of tests that would be first
here for most patients in the United
States and that would be the people you
know histochemical test in colonoscopy
for most patients and so for some reason
that would not be adequate or there's
patient preference the second-tier test
might be appropriate which would include
CT colonography a equal DNA test that's
usually in combination with the
communistic Emeco test and/or flexible
sigmoidoscopy and then and rarely would
go to a third-tier test like capsule
colonoscopy and I'll touch base on each
one of these in their sensitivity
shortly and the tests that of mal run
through here are obsolete
our fecal occult blood tests which have
now been largely replaced by the FI t
test and barium enemas which it's
sensitivity has been relatively poor and
most people do not like to take the
substance of a minima which may not
actually look at the entire colon anyway
so times have changed now just going
over these types of tests the strategies
for screening in the United States is is
the biggest one is probably colonoscopy
and generally if you have a colonoscopy
that shows
no polyps you would have intervals and
you don't have a strong family history
you would have integral of ten years if
the Colossians bigger for pops it's it
is very sensitive or significant lesions
that's large polyps and cancers and it's
sensitivity depending on which paper you
read ranges from eighty five and ninety
seven percent it is the test that is
also therapeutic so it gets a good luck
based on the operator doing the test but
it also can remove those lesions and in
fact there's lots of evidence by
removing polyps that you reduce greatly
your risk for giving colorectal cancer
however because it's uncomfortable there
is usually some conscious sedation or
some form of anesthesia given it
requires a prep and there is a modest
risk for perforation of the colon using
an instrument but it's the only
mortality for surveillance for high-risk
patients in other words if he had polyps
before or had a cancer before or is that
one any strong family histories its
colonoscopy that is the only test that
should be recommended in those
situations for routine screening it is
one of the tests the other one that has
nearly the same sensitivity for
significant lesions is CT colonography
isn't another test that uses non evasive
x-rays to render the colon in 3d and you
can get a virtual fly-through of the
colon however it does require prep
because you got to remove the faeces
from the colon it discounts small polyps
and it's diagnostic only so if something
is found at CT colonography it requires
a colonoscopy now here's some examples
of other tests some of these are less
invasive or non-invasive a flexible
sigmoidoscopy which is a shortened
version of the qin asti does not require
the same purpose of callosity you Jim it
requires
it's detection of significant lesions is
on the order of 70 to 85 percent and
only through the left colon or Sigma :
it does not reach the transverse or the
right hole in it so it does not the
technician is there so it's zero percent
of those areas and if you find something
on them generally we do a corn awesome
so you have to undergo a second test you
combine tests like but still super nasty
in a fit or FOBT test it says everybody
is sigmoidoscopy with the idea that the
other non sigmoidoscopy test with detect
lesions on the right side of where the
curiosity could reach but if any of
those test positive is doing the course
upon us a barium enema I mentioned is
pretty much obsolete its sensitivity was
and I'm generous on this slide and the
totally non-invasive test test its
sensitivity is 25 at 71% if it's
positive across colonoscopy FOBT which
has been largest matter so planet by fit
has a poor sensitivity is an expensive
boat and the more recent still equal DNA
tests are more expensive their
sensitivity is pretty good but it's cost
is what's and of course if that's
positive it requires a mouse anyway
there's other a couple of tests which
are not generally recommended not
momentum
capsule colonoscopy is not FDA approved
or lung cancer screening it's only
approved if the imaging the right column
is is it's not complete at colonoscopy
but it's Systema t4 adenoma sits fairly
decent 88% but it's poor forces all
Asians or lesions particularly on the
Left style :
there's also nut has cut the stuff
that was developed but its sensitivity
is on the order of 48% so very very poor
and that's only for cancers it's zero
percent for adenoma and that's you
really want to detect the benign
precursors of the cancer in order to
remove and there's some studies that
suggest that maybe since the late stage
cancer it's not even early stage cancers
which you want to find at the worst-case
scenario and during the screening method
so these are just several screen
strategies that I present here now you
know colorectal cancer I mentioned
135,000 your outcome is related to the
stage I mentioned that earlier thus if
you can detect you know early stage
tumors or the adenoma is because these
cancers to begin as Nova's polyps and
remove the adenoma should reduce your
instance as well as your mortality yes
and that's certainly the case in the
United States colonoscopy has become the
preferred method for most people
although there are some patients that
don't like the minimally invasive
strategies and this picture just depicts
colonoscope and in how its travel
traverses through the colon operator and
in the bottom photo there it shows the
act of polypectomy in which we use a
snare to either cold or hot stares can
remove those polyps and keep in mind
colonoscopy is diagnostic and
therapeutic it's communities for
screening and surveillance meaning your
average risk for sporadic or familial
and polypectomy it's the preferred
method for polypectomy which is the most
common procedure there's it's more
expensive than obviously a bit test or
FOBT test but because it
it's still relatively cost-effective now
one of the things about using this as a
screening modality is does it reduce
mortality answers yes
there have been this was really the
definitive paper this is a data from an
solver in the national pop study which
is a large cohort study that was New
York and this paid this table taken from
the new general Medicine article shows
that if you look at all comers for fall
time and looking at the observed deaths
compared to expected deaths for those
who cannot speak about those who were in
general population that the reduction of
deaths is on the order of 53% and that
didn't change very much whether you look
at someone who had a colonoscopy less
than 10 years are greater than equal to
10 years it was in the 51 to 56% hour
and those were statistically sweet okay
so the answer is yes colonoscopy can and
will and does reduce your chance of
dying from colorectal cancer and it's
largely due to remove of those at
anonymous pops the United States
Preventive Services Task Force just
about a year ago did a complete review
of many of the screening modalities used
to screen for colorectal cancer or
Accord and notice in this table which I
apologize for being somewhat difficult
to read just basically those of the
frequency for all these tests and the
evidence of efficacy and some other
considerations so and look in looking at
still based tests why people call blood
tests where you take a sample in the
stool passive homing put those on the
cards and mail goes in is not require
preparation
it's cheap but it's system is on the
people immuno chemical test
is now in the first tier for the multi
society recommendations it's relatively
inexpensive again does not require about
preparation or anesthesia and but
sensitivity is better than the fobt and
that's largely supplants the
FOBT the still DNA tests that's the
third one the United States promoters
Task Force recommends that there's
insufficient evidence about the launch
in the fall because it hasn't been
tested but they also show evidence that
it's expensive and other people have
shown that it may become cost effective
the cost particularly the DNA still
piece of that comes down the jerk
visualization test shown below I touched
base on he's already callosity CT
colonography flexible sigmoidoscopy and
combined plus the signal asking fit and
generally are for most part good
streaming strategies the colonoscopies
more expensive requires anesthesia prep
CT clonality requires prep but it's one
diagnostic the flexible sigmoidoscopy
only covers the left side of the colon
and even with the combination of
velocity that that test is probably
about a 75% sensitive as compared to
Coronado in their screening
recommendations they suggest that the
target population would be between 50
and 75 the risk assessment this is for
the vast majority of aperture cibele the
most important risk factor for
developing cancers age but other things
such as family history and and being of
african-american race should be in
consideration so I'll come back to that
later
and they also said that there's no
head-to-head studies on some of these
tests
so they're not sure which one's the most
affected one although in the United
States
colonoscopy has become the adopted gold
standard and other considerations such
as health and our screen of Spanish
taken in consideration for those who
have gotten much older such as over 85
or 86 in fact they recommend that those
aged six and older should never be
screened in more and those between 75
and 85 for screening should be weighed
and it's a consideration so really the
target audience is between 50 and 75 and
the average age of corner pants United
States is about 68 and that timeline
from developing normal to polyp to
cancer the normal to pop up might take
40 or 50 years and you get your first
polyps let's say by the time your age 50
and then it takes another 10 to 20 years
for you the cancer in the state average
ages around 68 so this is not something
that develops overnight so what are the
risk factors for developing colorectal
cancer things that are not modifiable
and mentioned in the US Preventive
Services Task Force recommendations are
age the older you are the more likely
your and get polyps or cancer in your
family history you have first and/or
second degree relatives that have had
chlorophyll cancer or polyps your risk
of getting colorectal cancer pops are
elevated and I'll show you that on a
upcoming slide the other thing that's
non-modifiable is your race and I'm
going to show you some data that raised
and in particularly United States
African American race and in some cases
Native Americans have higher risk for
developing these polyps these animals as
well as higher risk of developing and
dying from colorectal cancer now the
irregular is a lot of modifiable is your
diet your socioeconomic status although
that is harder to modify your
utilization for screening
health care access or insurability your
education the use of tobacco smoking and
I'll show you on the right-hand side of
this slide that even though most people
think of long and laryngeal cancer as
caused by smoking today the 10% of the
risk of colon cancer is from tobacco and
I show that with other things such as
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
which can lower your risk as well as
hormone replacement therapy particularly
a learner can lower your risk for cancer
and that has variable usage between even
races and socioeconomic status
so there's potentially modifiable but
some of these are societal modifiable
rather they non modify them like your
age family history or races that's
something that you can never change so
in thinking about age there is a
proximately 5% prevalence of all
Americans for animals that are greater
than 9 millimeter by the time we're 50
usually if you look at this curve shown
on this slide showing some around age of
50 years about 25% of us who are that
age or older will have an adenoma spot
this precursor age and as you can see
over time as we age the chances of
getting by time are 75 is about 50% so
we developed adenoma
25% of us will have them by now what
happens with cancer no cancer is a
consequence of some of those add Nova's
and we started screening recommendations
that are age 50 don't just put this
arrow but if you draw a line here at age
50 95% of all correct answers are after
the age with the average age of 60
and only 5% of cancers are below the HP
so you can see this curve goes
dramatically up just around age 50 and
this is why that age is picked for a
screen a general population
now I mentioned five percent of cancers
are below the age 50 that is largely
could be sporadic but that can also
include familial high-risk where your
genetic predisposition is extremely high
for develop cancers now
so that's age so your risk of developing
and no one cancer go up what about your
family history
well this table I put together shows
what your is changed so you look at the
averages there's no average risk of an
American no family history it's about
one in 18 to 1 in 20 so let's just say 5
percent of you developing a claw rectal
cancer somewhere between age of 0 and 75
years old so about 1 in 20 URIs
approximately doubles if you have a
first-degree relative that's mom dad
brother sister with either a cancer or
an ad no because we know the analyst the
pre-christian handsome so you have a
family relative first to be about you
doubled your lifetime risk if you have
to second-degree relatives so two people
in the family but maybe not but uncles
like any age with khloé' at the cancer
you possibly tripled
so family history is very important here
if you have a first-degree relative
last adenoma the precursor lesion that's
less than 60 you tripled your risk and
over to general population if you have
someone who's young relatively young
less than 25 years old colorectal cancer
youth six-fold increase your risk
because someone has it at a very young
age now if you have one of these genetic
syndromes in which the genetics dictate
and drive
pathogenesis cancer such as Lynch
syndrome or famosos unasyn
getting colon cancer are extremely high
because of the genetics that you've
inherited so 80% for Lynch syndrome and
a hundred percent of people with FFP
will get a colon cancer if they're
clones not removed so so Fanning is
she's very important for determining
them generally the guidelines up until
July of 2017 basically said men and
women so the the the split of cancers
between men and women are fairly equal
some part of this slide who are
asymptomatic and who are 50 years or
older should and they have a negative
family history would get average risk
screening in which the new
recommendations recommend one of the
tier one test that's fi T or colonoscopy
if you have a positive family history
and you have the first year or two more
second-degree relatives then you change
that age from 50 down to 40 years
because of that family history so we
would start routine screening for those
women family history at age 40 so the
determinants are typically your age and
your family history okay and and there
was no consideration of race until the
recent guidelines just published in July
of 2017
by the way if you do have a family
history because it's unknown whether you
might have a genetic syndrome on that
colonoscopy used to prefer tests with
that now so I mentioned up until July
when setting race was about included in
those guidelines now this was data from
the NCI
can substitute that looks at all races
and then breaks up into the five main
races in United States whites blacks
Asians American Alaskan Natives and
Hispanics and if you look at the
incidents whether male or female or the
deaths from colorectal cancer whether
male or female the highest is in the
african-american population by far so
looking at male the all races is about
forty six point nine per 100,000 and the
US population whites are about that
average in black a black males 12 fold
that's just me 12 points higher Asians
have lower rates and an Alaskan American
natives are elevated above lights but
not to the level of blacks Hispanics are
even lower than the average same same is
true for females and if you look at
deaths again African American males and
females comparing into those races other
races have the highest death rates for
colon cancer I do also want to point out
if you look at people aged 20 to 44
remember I said that there's about 5% of
people get colon cancer below the age 50
even those rates are still highest in
particularly black the black population
United States if you look at staging so
how to what extent do people present
with the colon cancer shown here on the
left so all races are in red lights are
in the green bars and black patients are
in blue bars so shown by the red arrows
above that so black patients for
mobilize have slightly less localized
disease by one percentage point
much lower regional disease but much
higher distant disease or metastatic
disease and these are standardized for
age there's only difference series rates
you look at the survivability so again
bread is all racist why whites are green
and black patients are in blue if you
have localized disease your survival
rate if you're black is four points
lower than if you were white even with
localized disease if you look at
regional disease which are still curable
by surgery that was a seven point lower
survivability regionalisms and if you
look at distant disease which kills you
know joints the survival for most
patients it was still even worse for
black patients and if you look at all
stages there is associate more
difference in survivability if you could
even come in with the same stage as
other patients so that that's clearly
and this has been consistent data for
the past 15 20 years without by the
National Cancer Institute if you look at
the trends over time on this next slide
white patients are shown in blue and
black patients are shown the red bar and
this shows the rate per hundred thousand
over a span of 20 to 30 years the black
line shows goes up if there's a larger
disparity between blacks and whites so
he showed if he see that both blacks and
whites rates for colorectal cancer have
declined over the last two or three
decades but the disparity that they're
declining at a slightly different slope
such that the disparity not shown by the
black line has gotten slightly larger
but it's pretty much leveling off he's
of no last name ten years if you look at
women again
blacks and whites have declined and the
gap has narrowed such that the the
disparity has stabled an aerial overtime
most people believe that this has to do
with screening but only time will tell
that so why are they erase our
differences I just showed you in a
previous slide
some would argue and these are it's
probably multifactorial but someone
argue that social economic status
insurance and education limit the
ability to have access to say screening
blacks make up about 13 14 percent of
the u.s. population but 24 percent of
the newest poorer population compared to
8% joins access to medical care is
different and moves on if your inner
city if you have insurance
although the Affordable Care Act which
was put in place in 2014
theoretically could modify that and that
time will tell if that type of
insurability it's going to be continued
or not what about the use of colonoscopy
I mentioned colonoscopy is kind of moved
to the gold standard in the United
States and you remove the powers there's
some evidence that there is a
right-sided excess of polyps in the
african-american population and if let's
say if the African American population
was largely flexible sigmoidoscopy they
would miss out on that compared to other
populations other things that are
theoretically modifiable but diets might
be different amongst races your city or
the food islands that in which you're
eating things that are not good for the
local colonic environment such as a
high-fat red meat low fiber type diet
these activity may be said tobacco the
must use of hormone replacement therapy
or incense
or even classic differences in biology
or general metastasis including mistrust
of the health system based on historical
other experiments have been done might
explain something's it's largely
probably multi factorial but I'll
explore a few of these things in the
next slides you look at risk factors and
this is also taken from seer data that
if you compare blacks versus whites on
obesity if you look at all
black patients tend to be more obese 48
percent covered 36 percent and that
seems to be more dramatic in women as
shown in this institute overweight maybe
not much different but that's slightly
less than obesity what about physical
activity so no leisure time visited mean
your are you more sedentary and that
seems to be higher along all blacks
compared to whites and these funding
this survey what about recommendations
for aerobic activity so this goes with
his activity again the numbers for
blacks seem to be the lower aerobic
activity more sedentary lifestyle which
is more associated with developing
cancers and what about the use of
tobacco if you look at All Blacks vs.
all whites not much different but black
men I had a couple percent of points
higher for UC tobacco which could
contribute to the development of cancer
disproportionate if that population uses
more tobacco
what about screening usage in other
words if the screen uses less you're
more like this you cancel because you're
not screening for and this survey also
take your National Cancer Institute
looking at blood testing any form of
endoscopy which could be flexible
sigmoidoscopy and or philosophy
the combination to and the survey which
I think was done in 2014 was not
dramatically different between blacks
and whites at this stage and this is
this is actually good news because in
past their survey data showed that well
there was a disparity
this means more blacks have been in
screening and our comparable to whites
so based on this data it might not be
that just screening utilization cell is
a driver for that disparity the type of
screening could make a difference though
but based on this survey there appears
to be not much difference what about the
distribution of colorectal cancer well a
number of surveys and studies have shown
that blacks tend to have more lesions on
the right side of cone of proximal colon
than whites data from the NCI ah--this
ear in one study this is a couple of
decades old but showed a 10% increase in
the number of proximal significant
Asians and blacks compared to whites if
you look at another study that came a
decade later blacks compared to whites
where whites were the reference so
they'd be 1.0 Asians had mess on the
right side with less likely as well as
Latinos but blacks they crossed that one
and they were about 7 percent white more
likely in this study there go 10 percent
in the older study of having a
right-sided lesion which are much more
difficult to get to and may not be seen
with certain screening tests if you look
at this in a how the pots are
distributed in another study this is a
study that looked at real-world 67 adult
GI practices where they had over
eighty-five thousand participants
including blacks and whites the two
things to show here blacks had 7.7% of
significant polyps that were
than nine movies and sighs the ones that
are more likely to turn in cancer
compared to 6.2 percent or white so they
have more advanced lesions if you and if
you look at black woman versus white
women circle the odds ratio was one
point six to a black woman having more
likely to have an advanced pause and one
point one six for black men they have
advanced compared to white men now I
know this is a complex slide but I'll
just point to where the arrows this is a
study done on over 320,000 average risk
adults looking at 84 adult Praxis
looking at finding two more polyps that
were nine movies are greater in
comparing blacks and Hispanics parenting
whites so if you look at the females or
males okay and I've highlighted with the
red arrows almost every five years of
age after age 15 the red arrows mean the
numbers were higher for black patients
and whites for females essentially every
five years was higher in the black
greater than ratio of one except for age
seventy seventy four for some reason and
if you look at males the younger ones or
did not cross the 1.0 threshold but
every other five years showed that
blacks had much more much more likely to
show 9 millimeter polyps or greater
which are the higher risk pops and so
this is just again or standardized for
age that for some reason black patients
tend to have more advanced polyps in
white patients at the same age it's not
clear why if you look at the
distribution of pops the proximal or
right colon versus the left hole in
black patients so
a number of 54 whites it's evenly
distributed about 50% proximal 50%
distal but look at the difference for
blacks more 53% were proximal compared
to 46% of 47% disto and if you look at
the other races like Hispanic they had
less on the right side so this seems to
be the pattern in many studies that
there were more advanced pops and blacks
and tend to be more of a proximal
distribution for some of the palms this
is a different study from Kaiser
Permanente again looking at a thing on
the range of 60,000 patients in this
study again a number of greater than one
what mean was cuz white was the
reference would mean that there were
more Hye RIS antonyms and in this case
they looked they broke down the racist a
little bit more granular blacks were 15%
higher than whites as shown in the other
study Asians were pretty close to whites
but here in Native Americans had the
highest risk even higher than blacks in
this particular study the numbers if I
recall were small in terms of number of
Native Americans but this is significant
and the same thing occurred for women
with similar larger numbers than whites
and as well as for men if you break it
down by gender so what this means is
that as similar to the previous days I
showed you that blacks didn't have more
high-risk adenomas and in this in this
particular study so the Native Americans
that Kaiser Permanente's study also
looked at the right side of distribution
or the distribution of the Pops and
similar to the lieberman study they were
i know this is hard to read but they
were about 26% more polyps compared to
whites on blacks and believe 55% for
native americans for any possible and
when you look at distal adenoma native
americans blacks I'm sorry
blacks had were one point zero nine so
nine percent higher and forty two
percent higher for Native Americans so
there was a proximate distribution but
they also grew because they grew more
advanced pops they also grew up on the
left side as well so so what about
developing in corn the palms on the
right side they atoms on the right side
there seems to be increased right side
prevalence I just showed you some
studies keep in mind colonoscopy is not
as effective in reducing mortality with
right side leading even really has a
complete visualization of the colon
there's been a number of studies showing
that its sensitivity for reducing
mortality on the right side is lower
than on the left side and it may have to
do with flatter polyps much more
difficult see polyps on the right side
and it's a further distance from the
entry of the otoscope the combination of
having right-side polyps and difficult
to see even with the gold standard test
colonoscopy could even amplify the
magnitude of the disparity of any
condition which has excess right side
cancers so you tend to have more rights
like cancers and got a test that doesn't
detect it as well that disparity will
grow there's also I mentioned so
saturated polyps or had known as early
on these there's very little race data
on these these tend to be more likely on
the proximal so one question is are
these excess proximal polyps are they
success rate and knows which have a
higher risk of turn cancer they show
microsatellite instability in the side
but there's very little data on this
and the one study that had enough
patience it was point two percent in
Caucasians than point three percent in
african-americans and there was no
statistical difference so on so Sasa
rating analyst is probably not the game
changer so it's unclear why and what
type of lesions are more on the rocks
inside and african-americans and
possibly Native Americans compared to
Caucasians
so the thought process is that some of
these cancers why are they more advanced
and there's now data from several papers
that suggest that the amount of cancers
below the age 50 is much higher Nazca
mountains so remember I said earlier
screen starts at age 50 of which about
five percent of the cancers are below
age 50 and ninety five percent above age
50 well if you look at the Americas for
african-americans it turns out that
there's double that amount so ten point
six percent of cancers in
african-americans or blacks are below
the age 50 if you started screened at
age 45 for african-americans
you'll equate that 5 percent to the same
curve so you start screen at 45 for
African turns it would equate to the
same number of cancers by age 50 at the
start at age 54 white patients so over
all African Americans 10 2 percent zero
to 8 years younger and applies the
analysts were initiated an earlier stage
so that's an implication but there's no
scientific evidence for that yet and
that means there's less time from age 50
to the average age of clone at the
cancer shortening the window for
screening intervention so there's been a
proposal that will come up in a slide as
I near closing out that recommends
moving the age of screening for African
Americans down to 45
what about family history remember I
said the screening algorithm you have
first and second-degree relatives that
you would start screening age 40 well it
turns out this data largely from the
social medical media Suzie not social
media social medical literature the
african-american and Hispanics with
family history colon cancer are least
likely of all races to get screened and
african-americans are less likely than
most races to know or transmit knowledge
of family history
so they it might be the dirty secret and
family or strange whatever but that
information is critical because that
determines whether you are average risk
in screening 50 or if you have family
members persecuted and some
second-degree rows that would put you at
age 40 so if you're not transmitting
that data you're gonna get screened at
50 based on recommendations unless you
transmit that that that you have family
members that present at a younger age or
or have cancer or now there's another
wrinkle to this too because there are
different pathways for colorectal cancer
to develop one is called the microcell
instability pathway
another one is microcell a stable it
turns out that if you have the
microsites the motor pathway which is
about 15% of all colon cancers you
actually have better survival compared
to those who have microsatellites stable
those cancers do create a be a right
Cohen's that could match
african-americans the mechanism tends to
be methylation of one of the genes that
cause our sensibility in which one
but unfortunately data suggests that
this mechanism is less common amongst
African Aries so there's more right sign
of medians but the MSI is not what's
found
and in fact if you look at those at my
croissants table and particularly
manifests another biomarker called a
mass the survival is poor and this is
the one that tends to be more common
amongst African Americans despite it not
necessarily being right side of Asians
so it's still unclear why there are more
right solutions they spend not to be
this better surviving in the side but
most of the lesions that contains a mass
which causes poor survival a more common
amongst Americans now this is important
because now there's therapies that can
affect your outcome so it turns out if
we got the MSI high phenotype which I
just told you that it was less common
african-americans it turns out there's a
drug an immunologic drug that can
further improve survival and those have
a Massiah tumors so if you if you don't
have any Messiah team when this drug
doesn't work very well so if you're at a
population such as African Americans
then don't get these types of tumors
this drug won't work very well so this
has implications on how patients are
treated other likewise is indications on
other treatment one of the mainstays of
treatment for advanced colon cancer is a
drug called five four years or five fu
as a number studies that show a clue
says we've done that pay if you have an
MSI high tumor which is less common
african-americans there is essentially
no benefit of chemo in fact in some
there's some studies just give bother
from you and also in a steamer you
shorted survival in some of these
patients
now if african-americans that less is on
high five with you would theoretically
be better because there's less than it's
not high
more like solid stable and they should
improve but yet that still has not been
demonstrated in fact the outcome is
still poor
so this does not answer one of the
questions of why of a percent and static
state but it does suggest that the
biology of the tumor can dictate how
these drugs could work so overall I'm
going to say that clover the cancers
generally begin that polyps but they can
progress screening typically begins at
age 50 unless you have strong family
history in which the age drops to 40 for
those particular patients prior to July
2017 race had not been considered in the
guidelines but if you look at
african-americans in particular and to
some degree Native Americans it's a
higher mortality early age of onset look
at the biomarkers of the MSA high which
is a good outcome they have half the
rate after members have half the rate
and double the rate of the bad biomarker
enos comparable lights it has
indications for the use of drugs
and there's also a higher number of
right-sided polyps and cancers but it's
not clear on the mechanism or even mr.
logic formation of these tumors and
that's an area ripe for study if you
look at the cost-effectiveness now I
know this is old data but the principle
is still the same amongst racial groups
because african-americans percent at a
younger age in more advanced they are
the group that is being most cost
effective for screening whether you look
at a combination of people called blood
tests and someone asks me with a five
years old a five-year long time or
colonoscopy every 10 years with a five
or ten year all time meaning how long it
takes to develop those pops of cancers
the african-americans or blacks are the
lowest in terms of cost because they
tend to resonate younger and more
advanced compared to other races so
they're very cost effective
so cost is not really an issue here if
you look at principles for screen if you
have a high risk condition I mentioned f
AP and Lynch syndrome I could mention to
planetary Bob as these are I mean most
gas Carabas are and others are aware
that risk and they will screen a more
severe than the risk of
african-americans is less likely being
known and that's one reason I'm giving
this webinar less likely known amongst
gas relatives and other physicians
because they'd is not necessary
front and center there but if you look
at any high risk whether it's FAPE
monster or whatever you would think as
long as it met those screening
parameters of sensitivity specificity
cost-effectiveness etc the screening
would begin before the age of
significant increase in cancer incidence
for that particular group and screening
should be adjusted by the observed
biology risk so for Lynch syndrome we
start screening them at varying ages 25
doing colonoscopies not every 10 years
but every other year and by then every
year and it's because we know the
biology of Lynch sir if you look at
recommendations based on race up until
July the American College gas neurology
didn't recommend age 45 years however
they were the body that most insurances
look at to pay for that the American
College of Physicians our ACP even the
lower and recommended screens are age 40
years for African Americans and that's
just the match quote-unquote having a
family history this is to for clinical
systems improvement recommend forty five
years like the American College
astrology but the two shown in green the
multi societies task force and US
Preventive Services Task Force are the
two agencies that really most insurances
petition for and really change policy up
until July they both
in standard 15 years for
african-americans despite some of the
vague I showed you now how could you
reduce the disparities that I've been in
Athens there are a lot of things that
could be thought patient education if
there's barriers to getting screening
physician education I mentioned not
every evening - neurologists know some
of the issues that are specific for
certain races patient navigation that's
a hot topic in which patients are offer
screening but because of life issues and
other things getting into the screening
site and getting the screening done is
much more facilitated with patient
navigation and one of the pioneer areas
in the city of New York where they're
getting screening rates even amongst
minorities - 80 percentile utilization
but increasing screening age by any
method 50 would increase to three rates
amongst african-americans and we know
that most colorectal cancers still occur
after age 50 that might be the modality
could be different or difference amongst
different races modify the age for
screening as I suggested some of the
major societies recommended 45 or 41
reduce the burden of early onset disease
and raises awareness of that in that
particular group but does have the
disadvantage of increasing confusion in
guidelines and again most colon cancers
develop after the age of 50 however in
the July published July recommendations
by the municipal test society Task Force
for the first time ever they did include
race to be considered in these national
guidelines and they stated quote
screening should begin at age fifty
years an amateur's persons except in
in whom limited evidence supports
screening to begin so this is something
that just happened in the past two
months and we'll see if insurance will
pay for it at age 45 versus 54 I will
stop there say thank you thank you so
much stuff and cares for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation window
typing those questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click on the
send button well answer as many as we
can before the before the end so let's
get started we have a wonderful audience
today our first question is what might
be the best strategy to lessen the
disparity between races I did mention
everything from education physician
education increasing screening examples
I'll be the be some combination of those
approaches there's no question that
patient and/or physician education about
some of the disparities and I didn't
even talk fully about Native Americans
and theirs their increase for a full
manner but I think education amongst all
races are getting a screen age 50 that's
beneficial no matter what race but to
lower the disparity that means targeting
those populations lower than the
screening age as mentioned by the new
guidelines
we'll probably help some and put some
attention on that but probably not
reduce everything because not only are
people developing particularly
african-american younger age but the
burden of disease is still hot even over
age 50 so I think you have to do a
combination of those things making sure
your screen is a ssin approaches and
perhaps lowering the speaking age
everyone on the scene I'll say risk so
thank you so much and thank you our
audience what an energetic group we
actually have time to answer one more
question today before we close but the
presenter will be emailing answers to
the other remaining questions
our last question from our audience
member before we close is what do you
think are the major biological
differences and having earlier cancers
in african-americans that shape the
environment in the colon and this comes
down to probably other metabolic
parameters that are within the core so
the way at least think of things I
started out with presentation talking
about taking a genetically susceptible
individual and expose him to embark the
environment and in the colon the lot of
the biggest driver that environment are
the things that you eat and then are
metabolized can you imagine it you know
and so we know that for instance I
diets high in red meat the the so called
westernized diet does put anyone and
everyone at a much higher risk but Co
not the cancer and we know this because
some of the other studies in countries
in which are not on westernized diets
there may be genetically susceptible
individuals there but they don't develop
colorectal cancer I always think of the
Japanese as in a great example in pre
World War two Japan we've had who are
largely on a rice and fish died their
rates of colorectal cancer were pretty
low compared to the United States but
immigrants who came from Japan to work
in the United States pre-world War two
on the west coast of the United States
within one or two generations had rates
similar to the United States that tells
you that this is largely not genetic or
that difference but that environment in
this case the type of food that they eat
over those generations probably
influenced may be other things tobacco
use in other days I also look at what
happened in post-world War two Japan
pulse will go to Japan after the who
ended there was a renaissance of
building and rise of economic power and
many of the Japanese ate more
westernized they're still the coast of a
fish diet but those who went to a more
westernized there was evidence that
their rates of colon cancer surpassed
that of the United States because of
their westernized diet so in that case I
would say that the Japanese were
probably always genetically more
susceptible to colon cancer but you
never saw because they never ate the
westernized diet until that manifested
itself at the right time in our history
and now their clinical cancer rates are
higher the United States I would say the
same thing is probably
Americans there's probably certain diets
particularly many inner cities or poor
areas and this made true for you not
Africa's employers where their microbial
makeup a much higher risk and I you know
the great experiment would be to take
that same person and put it in a
different environment given a different
socioeconomic class give them a
different diet and watch them over the
next ten years
watch that microbiome change and see if
that reduces their risk for cancer so I
think that's a great question
but I think this there's a lot of
studies trying to answer that they're
complex studies but I think it's going
to it's going to come down to probably
thank you so much dr. carrithers and
thank you for your informative
presentation and your important research
I'd also like to take the time to thank
labret swimming today's educational
webcast possible before we go in a lake
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January 2018 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share the announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon bye bye